[Music]
the onset of cancer usually begins as a
solitary tumor in a specific area of the
body if the tumor is not removed cancer
has the ability to spread to nearby
organs as well as places far away from
the origin such as the brain so how does
cancer move to new areas and why are
some organs more likely to get infected
than others
the process of cancer spreading across
the body is known as metastasis it
begins when cancer cells from the
initial tumor invade nearby
normal tissue as the cells proliferate
they spread via one of the three common
routes of metastasis trans coelomic
lymphatic or hematogenous spread in
trans coelomic spread malignant cells
penetrate the covering surfaces of
cavities in our body these surfaces are
known as peritoneum and serve as walls
to segment the body cavity malignant
cells in ovarian cancer for example
spread through peritoneum which connects
the ovary to the liver resulting in
metastasis on the liver surface next
cancerous cells invade blood vessels
when they undergo hematogenous spread as
there are blood vessels almost
everywhere in the body malignant cells
utilize this to reach more distant parts
of the body
finally lymphatic spread occurs when the
cancer invades the lymph nodes and
travels to other parts of the body via
the lymphatic system as this system
drains many parts of the body it also
provides a large Network for the cancer
in addition the lymphatic vessels empty
into the blood circulation allowing the
malignant cells to undergo hematogenous
spread once at a new site the cells once
again undergo proliferation and form
small tumors known as micro metastases
these small tumors then grow into
full-fledged tumors and complete the
metastatic process different cancers
have been known to have specific sites
of metastasis for example prostate
cancer commonly metastasizes to the bone
while colon cancer metastasizes to the
liver various theories have been
proposed to explain the migration
pattern of malignant cells
of particular interest are two
conflicting theories Stephen Padgett an
english surgeon came up with the seed
and soil theory of metastasis the seed
and soil theory stated that cancer cells
die easily in the wrong micro
environment hence they only metastasize
to a location with similar
characteristics however James Ewing the
first professor of pathology at Cornell
University challenged the seed and soil
theory and proposed that the site of
metastasis was determined by the
location of the vascular and lymphatic
channels which drained the primary tumor
patients with primary tumors that were
drained by vessels leading to the lung
would eventually develop lung metastases
today we know that both theories contain
valuable truths yet the full story of
metastasis is much more complicated than
either of the two proposed theories
factors like the cancer cells properties
and the effectiveness of the immune
system in eliminating the cancer cells
also play a role in determining the
success of metastasis unfortunately many
questions about metastasis remain
unanswered till today understanding the
exact mechanism holds an important key
to finding a cure for advanced stage
cancers by studying both the genetic and
environmental factors which contribute
to successful metastasis we can pinpoint
ways to shut down the process the war
against cancer is a constant struggle
and scientists are hard at work
developing new methods against
metastasis of recent interest is
immunotherapy a modality which involves
harnessing the power of the immune
system to destroy the migrating cells
this can be done in different ways such
as training immune cells to recognize
cancerous cells via vaccines the growth
and activity of the immune cells can
also be stimulated by injecting man-made
interleukins chemicals which are usually
secreted by the immune cells of the body
these two treatments are only the tip of
the iceberg with the collaborated
research efforts of governments
companies and scientists perhaps the
process of metastasis will be stopped
for good
you
[Music]